president reagan loved it test audiences
were puzzled by it and princess diana
was at the world premiere great scot
seeing back to the future in 1985 sure
sounds like a trip let's go back in time
some films take a while to find their
audience even movies that are later
considered classics don't always receive
a warm reception at the box office or
enjoy favorable reviews when they first
come out but not back to the future from
the start film reviewers from major
publications like the new york times and
variety all gave the movie glowing
reviews some like newsweek's jack kroll
called the film quote the smartest
sweetest funniest comedy in many summers
others like empire's adam smith praised
the screenplay an observation that would
be echoed in film classes for decades
film critic roger ebert was particularly
complimentary giving the flick three and
a half out of four stars in his review
ebert compared the film to the all-time
classic it's a wonderful life praising
the hopeful way it allowed audiences to
see their parents in a new life director
robert zemeckis also received accolades
from the legendary critic with ebert
claiming that his touch gave the film
quote charm brains and a lot of laughter
considering that the project was turned
down 40 times by multiple studios before
being made the warm critical reception
to back to the future had to be
extremely gratifying
one of the funniest moments from back to
the future came when the doc brown of
1955 asked marty who the president of
the united states was in 1985 and then
reacted with disbelief when he heard
that actor ronald reagan would become
president reagan in the future who's
president of the united states in 1985
ronald reagan ronald reagan the actor
according to his former speech writer
mark weinberg reagan who viewed the film
for the first time at camp david got a
kick out of an early scene where marty
walked by a 1955 movie theater
advertising the reagan film cattle queen
of montana when doc had his famous
exchange with marty however the mood at
camp david darkened not because of doc's
comment about reagan but because the
character then sarcastically asked i
suppose jane wyman is a first lady
wyman was reagan's first wife whom he
divorced in 1949 by 1955 he was married
to future first lady nancy reagan while
the movie completely ignored that fact
reagan didn't according to weinberg
there was a quote unspoken ban on
mentioning wyman among the reagan staff
making the film's reference to her a
very uncomfortable moment
despite his brief discomforts at the
mention of ex-wife jane wyman by doc
brown president ronald reagan became a
big fan of back to the future his speech
writer weinberg would later recall that
both ronald and nancy reagan were
impressed by michael j fox's performance
as marty mcfly this may have been
related to the fact that fox was also
playing republican teenager alex keaton
on the reagan's favorite television show
at the time family ties weinberg said
that reagan remarked about back to the
future
this was the type of movie that
hollywood should be making
six months later president reagan even
quoted back to the future in his
february 4 1986 state of the union
address encouraging the american people
to look to the skies as the limits of
their achievements reagan said as they
said in the film back to the future
where we're going
we don't need roads
zamakis ultimately chose to use a
delorean as the basis for his time
machine partly because the gull wing
doors of the car would allow a 1955
family to mistake the vehicle for an
alien spacecraft when marty crashes into
their barn although ford offered the
production team money if they made the
time machine out of a mustang co-writer
bob gale reportedly responded with quote
doc brown doesn't drive a mustang
the time machine's stylish and memorable
design earned the filmmakers praise from
the sports car's original designer john
delorean by 1982 the delorean motor
company had gone bankrupt and its
factory closed this ended delorean's
dream of creating a quote ethical sports
car thanks to back to the future however
the delorean dmc 12's image was
immortalized realizing the movie had
kept his dream alive john delorean sent
the filmmakers a fan letter thanking
them for using his car
john delorean wasn't the only fan of
back to the future that loved the car
the film fueled a major delorean
collecting craze that persists to this
day reportedly the delorean motor
company only managed to produce over 9
000 dmc 12s before the company went
bankrupt in 1982. however thanks in part
to back to the future an estimated 6 500
delorean cars are still on the road
today this is in sharp contrast to other
discontinued car models which normally
phase out of existence once they stop
being made ironically in 1984 former
delorean dealer steve lopinto claimed
the car quote doesn't have enough
mystique to become a collector's car
flash forward to 2011 when someone
purchased an original back to the future
delorean for 541 thousand dollars
thankfully deloreans that didn't appear
in the film are much more affordable a
1981 dmz 12 went for 23 100
at an auction in 2019
of course many delorean car collectors
don't just want a classic sports car
they want the time machine from back to
the future this led many fans to modify
their deloreans and make them resemble
doc brown's iconic design among these
builders are oliver and terry holler who
spent three and a half months refitting
a delorean sports car with scrap metal
and surplus electronics to recreate the
back to the future time machine today
the hollers volunteer for the michael j
fox foundation for parkinson's research
they aren't the only delorean fanatics
in the documentary back in time fan joe
waltzer recalled that he promised he
would buy a delorean and turn it into a
time machine today waltzer is on the
time machine restoration team and helped
restore one of the original delorean
time machines after it fell into
disrepair on the universal studios movie
lot
if you look closely at the dates on doc
brown's time machine you'll see that
marty mcfly first drove the time
traveling delorean on october 26 1985 in
the parking lot of twin pines mall which
was actually puente hills mall in city
of industry california however back to
the future was released to the public on
july 3 1985 almost four months before
the film's events took place
this led a group of fans to show up at
the puente hills mall on october 26 1985
to see if marty or doc brown would
appear in the famous delorean
unfortunately neither character made a
real life appearance but that didn't
stop another group of fans from showing
up at the puente hills mall again in
october 2015 to see if doc or marty
would suddenly appear 30 years later
this time the owner of a delorean time
machine replica was on location to give
fans a fun photo op
in the documentary back in time michael
j fox recalled that during the 1985
world premiere of back to the future he
was seated next to none other than
princess diana who was attending the
screening with her then husband prince
charles prior to the event fox and the
other attendees received a list of rules
for how they should interact with
british royalty among them they were
forbidden from turning their backs on
the prince or princess and could not
speak unless spoken to unfortunately
shortly after the movie began fox
realized he had to go to the bathroom
and found himself in an uncomfortable
position he couldn't walk away from
princess diana without turning his back
on her and he couldn't excuse himself
since he was instructed not to speak to
her
so the whole the whole thing was
i sat in total pain watching the movie
with the princess of wales and it was
great
it was i think she was smoking hot
before back to the future was officially
released on july 3rd 1985 a test
audience got to see the film when it
first screened in may of 1985 at the
century domes theater complex in san
jose california unlike a premiere there
were no signs or hints suggesting what
the movie would be about people did get
excited when the opening credits
revealed that the film was created by
steven spielberg and robert zemeckis but
many still had no idea what to expect
bob gale recalled years later when doc
brown sent his dog einstein forward in
time one minute causing him to vanish
some audience members were distressed
because they thought the dog had been
killed of course these viewers didn't
realize the film was a comedy
today when people think of back to the
future they think of the entire trilogy
to a contemporary audience it appears
that zemeckis and gayle always planned
the story to be an epic three-part tale
after all the infamous words to be
continued appeared at the end of the
first movie right except that for
audiences who saw the film in 1985 they
didn't the original flick did indeed end
with doc brown taking marty and his
girlfriend jennifer parker to the future
but neither zemeckis nor gayle
envisioned the movie as anything more
than a standalone however when the film
became a huge hit the studio put
pressure on the filmmakers to continue
the story as a result when back to the
future was released on home video in
1986 mca universal added the words to be
continued at the end
this helped build anticipation among
fans as well as new viewers who saw the
movie for the first time on vhs tape
which was helpful since back to the
future part 2 wouldn't hit theaters
until 1989.
in 2002 the 2b continued ending was
removed again when the back to the
future trilogy was released as a dvd box
set
back to the future might be considered a
sweet comedy by many fans but it does
have some uncomfortable moments
particularly the scenes between marty
mcfly and his teenage mother lorraine
after marty is hit by the car that was
supposed to strike his father lorraine
falls for him unaware that marty is
actually her own son it was this subplot
that caused the movie to be turned down
by disney when zemeckis and gail were
looking for a studio to produce the film
gail would later recall we went in to
meet with an executive and he says are
you guys nuts are you insane we can't
make a movie like this you've got the
kid and the mother in his car it's
incest this is disney it's too dirty for
us
weirdly the incest plot proved popular
with at least one audience member in the
documentary back in time adam f goldberg
creator of the goldbergs tv show
recalled that his mother came back from
the movie theater in 1985 and told him i
just saw this amazing movie called back
to the future it's about a boy who goes
back and falls in love with his mom
her review immediately turned off the
younger goldberg for obvious reasons
although he later came around and became
a fan of the film that is
at its core back to the future is a
movie about keeping families together
this motivated a young dan harmon
co-creator of the back to the future
influenced adult animated series rick
and morty to make his parents go see the
film because they were separated at the
time in the documentary back in time
harmon said subconsciously it was like
maybe my parents will get back together
if
if they watch this they did get back
together
as huey lewis famously sings on the back
to the future soundtrack that's the
power of love
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]